day 72 yes our fellow americans their
families thousands of green card holders
siv applicants that we promised if this
day ever came we would would not abandon
them they were all abandoned by joe
biden day 85 since biden promised that
he would not leave any american behind
it's 56 days since your president even
mentioned all the men women and children
that he deserted and completely
abandoned to taliban terrorists in
september according to defense secretary
lloyd austin he said fewer than a
hundred americans remain trapped and
apparently lloyd austin was either lying
or was being lied to in fact the biden
administration just told congress that
in fact hundreds of u.s citizens today
remain in afghanistan 72 days later
joe's turned the page his press
secretaries in the media mob also have
abandoned any mention of their fellow
americans and that's not all according
to the secretary of state anthony
blinken there are still quote thousands
of u.s green card holders yep trapped
behind enemy lines in afghanistan people
that have a legal right to live in this
country thousands along with their
families and meanwhile u.s soldiers
stationed in syria were recently
attacked by iranian drones carrying
explosive charges thankfully no american
casualties tonight it is unclear whether
the biden administration plans to
respond in any way here now with more
former secretary of state fox news
contributor mark mike pompeo let's skip
around the globe a little bit let's
start in afghanistan they told us it was
under a hundred now we know it's
hundreds now we know it's thousands of
green card holders uh day 72 mr
secretary i don't see a lot of hope for
those people getting out alive and my
fear is a mogadishu or an isis capture
of americans and then we know what's
going to play out publicly
sean this is tragic
they clearly misled the american people
not only the president but the secretary
of defense as you talked about for the
longest time they talked about barely
triple digits we now know the there are
tens of thousands of people that have a
right to return back to the united
states of america our government has
done almost nothing to bring them back
that this is worse than just
incompetence this is an absence of
caring about
americans and those who have a right to
come to the united states of america
we've completely abandoned them the
president won't even talk about these
things
we are not serious we on our state
department twitter feed today we're
talking about
intersectionality and pronouns when
we've got americans behind enemy lines
in afghanistan this is this is a deeply
troubling it is disconcerting it is
horrific to the family members of these
people who are here in the united states
and we are responsible to get them back
i am now counting on private sector
efforts to do this and i hope that the
government at least not get in the way
of these brave
yes sean exactly i hope the government
will at least not get in the way of
these private groups who are trying to
get folks home well wait a minute the
state department said on a memo saying
oh if you have a chartered flight you're
not allowed to land in the u.s even when
u.s citizens are bored and if you get a
country that will accept your charter
you not our permission will not be
forthcoming if necessary let me move on
though to iran uh we see there now
hostile military actions against
americans on top of our envoy to iran
basically acknowledging that it looks
like iran's going to be a nuclear power
and they seem to be willing to accept
that i'm not willing to accept that
president trump and i weren't willing to
accept it either we made clear this
wasn't going to happen on our watch now
countries in the region certainly israel
that it the iranians continue to
threaten to wipe off the face of the map
but arab states as well can see that
america is not serious about defending
them from the risk of proliferation in
the region nuclear weapons in the hands
of perhaps multiple countries there if
the iranians get a nuke others are going
to want one too sean this is serious
business again and that it all comes
back to an absence of strength president
biden has demonstrated weakness remember
with respect to iran the iranians
launched missiles into israel within
days of them taking office they would
they would not have done that when we
were there they launched missiles from
gaza strip into israel the united states
took days to say that the israelis had
the simple right to defend themselves
what about china the the
flying of their fighter jets over taiwan
airspace talk about endless talk of
reunification
and then russia gets a waiver to build
their pipeline uh it seems like
preferential treatment for russia and
china and then my imagination takes me
to the fact that the
the biden family has made a lot of money
from both those countries fair question
fair question common theme
we had america first these folks have a
woke idea of national security whether
it's climate change or whatever it may
be
and they don't understand that american
power matters in the world we don't need
to send tens of thousands of our
soldiers to demonstrate that power we we
simply need to allow our energy
companies to produce our commercial
providers to have the economic power and
demonstrate the economic power and
unleash our military in a way that's not
political but forceful these are things
that the by administration simply
refuses to accept
they've adopted essentially the obama
policy of apologize for america wherever
they go it puts not only the united
states at risk but our friends and
allies not only in taiwan but in japan
and south korea and israel this is this
is serious stuff sean and this
administration better get a handle on
how to re-establish deterrence and
credibility who are in for an awfully
long next three years
all right
secretary pompeo great to have you as
always thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else